a group of climate wackos threw soup on
the Mona Lisa
yesterday they're speaking some sort of
barbaric tongue I don't know if that's
are they channeling demons or something
I can't quite make out what they're
saying but they are the
climate the climate action Maniacs who
keep traveling all over the world and
throwing soup on Priceless works of
[Music]
art and there's cops there but the cops
are those oh no those are activists
too where the where the cops where the
where the museum guards where are the
dosant even why won't someone tackle
these people and get them away from a
Priceless work of Western
Art these people these climate cultists
are like the Taliban blowing up the
ancient Buddha statues the Buddhas of
Bame in
Afghanistan except they're less
Justified at least when the Taliban blew
up the Buddha statues they were blowing
up Idols you know I'm not defending it
I'm not I I don't think the Taliban is
Justified in almost anything it does
but at least at least I can understand
why a monotheist might get rid of pagan
Idols here though these climate cultists
are blowing up beautiful pieces of
Western art or at least trying to or at
least trying to ruin them with soup why
because the climate cult has always been
about punishing our
civilization the climate cult I call it
a cult because it's like a cultist you
know it's it's it's a a form of religion
a perverted and false religion but it's
a form of religion that has all the
Hallmarks of religion it has the notion
of original sin it has the notion of
redemption it has an apocalypse and it
has an eschatology it it has
everything and in the climate
religion our civilization is the cause
of the fall in in the the climate cult
it's we in the west who have
industrialized we have polluted our
Earth and set the Earth on a course for
utter destruction and so only we can
save ourselves we need to stop driving
cars and stop having babies and stop
eating meat and stop
doing anything we need to stop living
and growing and
developing in order to I don't know save
the world so that's why they're not
going to destroy indigenous art they're
they're also not going to destroy Modern
Art because Modern Art also is about
punishing our civilization Modern Art
also is about is about feeling shame and
guilt and and uh looking at ourselves uh
as as uh decadent objects it's about
degrading us so of course no surprise
there whatsoever they want to punish our
civilization and a the great way to do
it Beyond telling us not dead families
anymore and and destroying what we eat
and destroying how we move and how we
live is destroying Beauty destroying
beauty is is perhaps the most efficient
way to demoralize a
civilization president Trump's trade
advisor Peter Navaro has just been
sentenced to four months in
prison for doing exactly what Hunter
Biden did well no I'm sorry not exactly
what Hunter Biden did you've probably
seen those clips you know with the
hookers and the drugs and the guns Peter
Naro never did any of that stuff not
exactly what Hunter Biden did in that
Peter Navaro never shook down foreign
oligarchs and sold American influence
for millions and millions of dollars he
never did
that Peter Navaro just didn't show up to
testify before Congress that's why he's
going to the clink for four months the
exact same thing that Hunter Biden did
Hunter Biden gets off Scott free Peter
Navaro was asked to appear before the
January 6th Committee in March of 2022
He was ordered to provide documents to
that committee one month prior he didn't
do either of those things citing
executive privilege this is a top
advisor to the president of the United
States and the Congress has absolutely
no right to drag him before them that
would be a um major weakening of the
separation of powers Congress is not not
absolute
Congress is not Supreme in the United
States Congress is one of the three
branches of government and they have no
right to do that so now the Judiciary
has sentenced Peter Navaro to four
months in prison He was ordered also to
pay a fine of 9500 bucks which is a
reduction by the way the US District
Judge Amit meta wanted to sentence him
to six months in prison and and find him
$200,000 that that was what the justice
department requested actually I'm being
fair to judge Amit meta judge Amit meta
was the one who heard this request and
then and then reduced that but it's
still ridiculous the guy sentenced him
to prison and charged him a bunch of
money for for what Hunter Biden did
Hunter Biden also defied a subpoena to
appear before the house oversight
committee for a closed door deposition
he didn't do it he held a big press
conference in front of the capital about
how he wasn't going to do it then he
made a big H blue inside the capital
later on about how he wasn't going to do
it and he gets off scott free completely
Lawless what's the point of this the
point of putting Peter Navaro a very
amiable e economic adviser into prison
is to demoralize the
right it's to discourage people ever
from working for Donald Trump even in
senior White House positions it's dis to
discourage anyone from ever
contradicting the liberal ruling class
because they'll say yeah if you if you
have a difference of opinion on trade I
mean think about this Peter Navaro he's
he's a protectionist Peter Navaro was
the pro tariff adviser in the Trump
White
House and the liberalist establishment
is globalist a lot of the the Trump
election was was about opposition to
globalism just as the brexit was about
opposition to globalism just as Victor
Orban in Hungary his election was about
opposition to globalism just like
Georgia Malone's election in Italy was
about opposition to globalism and the
lives they love globalism they hate
National borders they hate National
sovereignty they want to break all of
that down and have us all just be
governed by The Blob and so they go
after this guy in particular Peter
Navaro and Navaro
has stood very firm he just went on TV
to explain that throwing him in the
clink is about a lot more than just him
if anybody thinks U they're not trying
to put Donald Trump in prison for 700
years they need just need to look at
what they did to me yesterday they're
not messing around four months in prison
they they even want to put me in prison
before I can I can have my appeal in
this case uh and they want Trump in
prison and out of the Oval Office and
they want folks like me um not to be
able to help him out and here here's the
thing here's what I'd ask your viewers
to understand I am it's not rare I am
the first senior White House adviser
what they call Alter Ego to the
president ever ever to be charged with
this alleged crime and the irony here
Sean the irony is that the Department of
Justice itself has maintained a policy
for more than 50 years that says that
senior advisers like me absolutely
cannot be compelled to testify before
Congress why because it violates the
Constitutional separation of powers and
interferes with the ability of executive
privilege to V to provide effective
presidential DEC decision making totally
right if the Congress can jail senior
presidential advisers for refusing to
give them whatever ever they want and
show up whenever they want that is an
obliteration of the separation of powers
rather than having three co-equal
branches of government the legislature
the executive and the Judiciary now
we've just got a supreme
legislature and the executive works for
the legislature the president works for
the Congress that's not what I learned
in civic's class but no one learns
anything in civic's class anymore Peter
nar's Point really brilliant here so how
do you make sense of that how could the
doj which for 50 years has maintained
this policy of saying that the the
senior White House advisers can't be
compelled to testify before Congress and
provide documents to them how could the
doj then simultaneously prosecute a
trump senior White House adviser for
doing that because they don't view the
Trump White House as legitimate that's
why you want to talk about election
deniers and deniers of the legitimacy of
our sacred democracy it's the Biden
White House it's the doj that's doing
that they don't view Peter Navaro as a
normal senior White House adviser
because they don't View Donald Trump as
a normal president they don't view any
of them as legitimate so they anything
can be done to Trump and it and in their
minds it won't upset the Norms of our
sacred
democracy Yeah in our sacred democracy
we usually don't jail the opposition
leader but Trump's different we can't
normalize him yeah in our democracy we
usually don't jail former presidents but
Trump's different he was he's not a real
president he's a fake president his
voters they're not real Americans
they're deplorable irredeemable
Americans they don't deserve any rights
jail them too
you know any of them if any of them
happened to be walking even within 5
miles of the capital that day you know
maybe they were going to go get a drink
at Old ebbit Grill but yeah just go get
round them up too some Midwestern granny
was taking pictures on the National Mall
yeah get her too none of these people
are legitimate you you're not legitimate
you're a deplorable
irredeemable you you oppose Joe Biden
you're a threat to
democracy that's what this is about that
that's the way it does make sense is the
problem it it makes sense if you accept
their dangerous premises that half of
the country is not not legit or entitled
to political rights that was a good clip
huh
now ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel we'll see
you next time